let's start with a hollywood actor
meeting with ukrainian refugees and
using his platform to raise awareness
we're talking about orlando bloom who is
a goodwill ambassador for unicef he's
been doing that since 2009. during a
two-day trip he visited refugee centers
in moldova which borders southwestern
ukraine tens of thousands of ukrainians
have crossed into moldova and bloom
spoke exclusively to us about the
importance of helping those refugees
listen to what he told us
i have an 18 month old daughter and if i
if i i i just can't articulate what it
would mean to leave to take them to the
border and then let them go
to another country until every child is
safely in hand
you know we can't forget
so of course we've been talking about
since the start of the war uh that 1.8
million refugees have left ukraine uh
and many of those are obviously children
over 168 000 of those children have
ended up in moldova and people all over
eastern europe are opening up their
homes i have a friend who's lithuanian
she's based here in new york in
washington dc but her father has a
b and b in lithuania accepting ukraine
the numbers of the children though it's
something like over 4 million it's an
extraordinary amount of children that
have had to leave their own country can
you imagine as a little kid you have no
idea what is happening or why this is
happening walking with their little
stuffed animals and backpacks it's
heartbreaking to watch and that's why
orlando bloom decided to be out
there to all of those celebrities
speaking athletes exactly